we're just doing this kind of work for
the last like eight years
taught you about men
you better believe in polygamy
or you're gonna get your feelings
you're sharing your man and you're also
being shared by
your clients right
right
lots of polygamy going on in the
world all right heather
yeah
heather uh where'd you grow up where are
you from omaha nebraska omaha
and tell me about your family growing up
you had mom and dad mom and dad um they
were together until i was about ten
but pretty good childhood
no crazy abuse nothing like that
no not really
not really um no i would say just more
like
mother not showing
love so
not abandonment but sort of
not neglect
no just a business she was busy
yeah
called
what kind of gift were you in high
school
the
i was the bad one out of the family are
you the black sheep of your family yes
teenage pregnancy run away
emancipated at the age of 16.
so
what's behind all that
um i think that because you had a good
childhood
if you had a good childhood what's
behind all that
[Music]
me not being part of the perfect family
so it's best is this something you got
from one of your relatives or
something happened to you or what what
causes this
there was
some
abuse
[Music]
which i kind of blocked out
later on in life and now i'm dealing
with that oh i see
[Music]
did you go to college i did i
went to
i have a massage therapy degree that i
got out of omaha and
i also
did my cna and i have three years into
alternative medicine
so you're currently working as a an
escort um it's just like my side hustle
at this point okay but but you've been
doing it for how long eight years yeah
so you didn't start as a teenager like a
lot of i did not i started at 35. you're
35. yeah i had babies and was a mom you
were married no never married
my first daughter i had it 16 and then i
had my son at 20. did you raise your
kids i did um
no not all the way
my daughter my mother
was raised with my mother
and my son i eventually gave his dad
full custody
why did that happen um
when i left my son's father
um
some stuff happened my daughter was
moved out to my mother's house
um so it was me and my son i got into
domestic abuse
and gave my son to his dad so he didn't
witness that were there drugs in your
life um heroin
i went from xanax
and
norcos
and
full-blown just a mess
in and out of mental hospitals
and
was in a 12-year abusive relationship
and that's where
the drug use really started um
went from oxies and then didn't want to
be sick anymore
off of you know the
whatever so i went to full heroin
um
when i decided to leave home
it was like i went to north little rock
arkansas and
i was picked up by a pimp which i didn't
know was a pimp but i'm on the streets
and
called and literally one of the girls
that was sleeping with random people for
a blunt and a place to sleep
and
the guy found me off a tagged
and i didn't like i said i didn't know
that he was a pimp but after 12 years of
being in an abusive relationship to me
and stabbed me
he did six years
on attempted murder
when i looked in the car of the man that
pulled up there was heels
reeses
outfits and it just it looked
appetizing when you have nothing
and i got in the car and he said you
know your feelings go in your pocket and
we get money
and at the time coming from abuse it
sounded like the best
and drug use you know um
i almost did 20 years on prescription
narcotic distribution
i was telling my own medicine you said
yeah you said your feelings go in your
pocket yeah feelings go in your pockets
yeah what kind of it's horrible yeah
it's not great but
um very interesting
but when you're in your feelings and
they get hurt oh and hurt and hurt for
12 years
that sounded
perfect to me
um his but i got sober that was my first
day sober i've been sober since it was
march 13th
um
that was his thing
he had his girls healthy
and
so the game like it saved my life
so yeah he you got clean yep
i got very training from heroin yeah and
traded
my heroin addiction to
money addiction like it's really an
addiction like even when you try to stop
there's it's always there
is it the fast money that you're
addicted to is it the
certainly isn't love
i don't i don't know if it's like so
much the fast i don't i really don't i
don't know what it is it's like the
whole thing like
you know like a
a drug addict when they're they're
calling to get their their fix and and
they're going to get their fix and then
they get their fix
and then all of a sudden they're
depressed because they want the next fix
that's literally what it feels like yeah
but is it is it
in some way an extension or
a result of
the the sexual abuse you may have had as
a kid um i believe so um in some weird
roundabout way
i think that like
i don't know many females in this
industry who have respect for
a client
um we kind of find them disgusting and
gross
and i feel like in a way that i was
trying to get back at that person
through everybody else
even though i give them like the best
time
it's still in my mind like
they still have to
have to donate to me
have to rent me
and at the end i
that makes me powerful more powerful
than some form of revenge
and you've worked on the track you've
worked hard um when i left my first
folks i was in memphis tennessee i mean
just just to
explain when when when girls say they're
folks
that means you're pimples
it's your management it's your
it's whatever it's just okay yeah
it's who controls
you controls
you know
um
i can't say that i've really had it bad
um
you know from elevation dressing
you know how to speak proper
you know not be thuggish and you can be
a lady of the night and still
so your experience with your pimp is is
not so negative no
no um when i did walk a track i had left
my pet
i took direction from him for five
months and thought i could do it on my
own
um i ended up
on van buren street and 24th in phoenix
arizona i did not know it was a track it
was my first night ever sleeping outside
and
i don't know if the game gods said here
you go or what but
i learned how to walk the blade
and
i was in handcuffs super bowl sunday
and then i learned
the internet
and it was interstate after that and
i've moved
and lived almost everywhere on your own
or with a pimp again
pretty much on my own um i thought that
if i was gonna do this i was gonna do it
with a boyfriend so the money would
continuously always be in my pocket
some way even if it was in their pocket
physically it was still we're together
and that was the worst idea i could ever
had
because then i you speak and you tell
them how to run you without even knowing
that you're doing it right
so i want to be her boyfriend today in a
feeling
um
so
but it's uh
what is doing this kind of work for the
last like eight years
taught you about men
you better believe in polygamy
or you're gonna get your feelings
because your clients are married and
married um and then if you want to
choose to work with folks
there's
more likely going to be other females
and you need to know how to emotionally
deal with yourself
you're sharing your man and you're also
being shared by
your clients right
right
lots of polygamy going on in the world
some something like that yeah
you've been arrested
um yes i have i was arrested in my home
city
so um
it was a in call
and
greed will always scare you the wrong
way
and not all money is good money
so
my intuition has never been wrong and i
had already known
when the minute i got out the car to go
in there that
it wasn't right
you know yeah so i
went against
my gut feeling you went to you went
against your intuition
and ended up in handcuffs
so i stay away from nebraska
[Music]
does this lifestyle get you down you get
emotions that
become progress become desensitized
even when you hit different cities
and you don't feel
um
it's lonely
i
know that
us girls want you know
like you look in the airport and you see
these people like all lovey-dovey on
each other and you wonder like is that
ever gonna be part of your life
because that's not what goes on you know
we're only when you're being paid
does that stuff go on right
so your story is interesting because you
didn't start it as a teenager you
weren't
trafficked into this or tricked into it
or whatever
you you were a housewife with your kids
and you were living a fairly normal life
right
you uh
your drugs kind of got you in
into trouble yeah and then this is just
a new form of
of addiction of addiction
so i'm trying to fight my addiction at
this point
i want better
like i want to i guess write a book on
you know
survival
um
in the game
and
not it's not as bad of it
as other people make it look you know um
and i feel sorry for the girls who are
sick and can't get out like i really do
like i i don't know how to help them and
there's too many of them yeah very
difficult yeah because even if you get
them out
and you're protecting you you've got a
better lifestyle for them very often
they run back to their
situation yep it's an addiction
it's an addiction um
something that like gets a lot of us off
is
when we pass the money over
like the smile on his face knowing that
you're making him smile but like
then what
yeah i've heard it explained
by some of the pimps to me not on camera
but but it's
a sign that
the girls want to be of service
to their man to their parents
and they get off on that even being told
like
and i wouldn't say so much telling us
what to do but direction authority
they wanted maybe we didn't have that
they want to have a purpose and their
purpose is to make their man happy
i know a lot of people can't
wrap their heads around that but
yeah yeah there's a lot of things about
human behavior we can't understand
you either can be in it or you're not
gonna
i i believe it's actually one of the
toughest professions one of the
strongest as females out here like what
we endure and the mental
and to still wake up every day whether
you're getting you know they're getting
high or not you're still waking up every
day and dealing with some new trauma
yeah
what has it taught you about
human beings and
men and everything
relationships
you believe in love
love
i believe in
seasons
you believe in what seasons seasons yeah
i don't really believe in so much
love is hurt
and
love hurts
i don't
i think i love i mean you can i love my
kids
i love what came out of me
but
i don't
i don't know what love is at this point
do you think you could fall in love now
or have a relationship a romantic
relationship
if a man can
and i haven't met one
who can look past this lifestyle
and accept it yeah
and not be a pet
yeah
that sounds like a pimp
only only a tim could accept that
and that's hard cause we're there for
the moment you know we're replaceable
so when you say do you believe in love
like
if we love them do they 100 percent love
us back because like i said we're
replaceable
there's always going to be new better
you know what i'm saying like younger um
maybe somebody who's just
more for him
shows him something you didn't
is that love could a richard gere type
character or prince charming come along
like mr gray
for fifty shades of grey like we all
hope for that i
believe not a client you know what i'm
saying because once that
once they donate for your time
it's a whole different
you know
you don't respect that man anymore so
it's got to be somebody you meet
randomly and how do you do that because
you're programmed to not
intertwine with people unless it has to
do with being paid
you've been doing it for about eight
years how has it changed
uh isolated me
isolate isolate isolate there's so much
competition
and hatred
and things that will stop you from doing
what you're trying to do just out of
jealousy and greed and you're
you know see that you think people you
know
so a lot of isolation not telling
anybody what your next move is
because nobody can pray on your downfall
or your uphill crying you know
so
trust yourself be your own best friend
you gotta look in the mirror and that's
you'll love that person it doesn't
matter
who
or what or why anything else
how does this type of work impact your
self-worth
that's a mind over matter
it's a minor matter because all of us
you know are beautiful or we wouldn't be
in this
they wouldn't be purchasing us
you know um
but
i know that other people don't probably
think like that
because they're they're clouded
and they're not looking as pretty as
they once were or they
have folks that are not the proper folks
you know
gorilla whatever
they're doing
what do you what's your opinion on tips
because there's many different types of
pips
you had good experiences
i believe in proper management and
if i can hand you my money and i can see
that you're doing something
positive with it like we can be business
partners
but
there's too many different
[Music]
um there's too many different
types of pimps now
you've had one thing
oh no i've probably had a handful
but i don't know that in the pin world
that they're really pimps right but of
those relationships did you walk away
with anything
[Music]
so that's what i'm saying
you don't really
get anything out of that relationship no
that's why it's not left
[Music]
what advice would you give to a young
ladies or any any woman who's
considering doing this
you started late
so any woman um
if you're gonna do it you need to really
be prepared to do it
you need to be prepared with what comes
with it
and it's gonna come from all different
angles
you know um
with all seriousness
so if you're going to choose management
because that's really what's out there
i mean
somebody that's that's got businesses or
that's got
multiple things going for themselves and
they might not even be dressed in the
best clothes
you know but their bank account shows
that
you know or that invests in you you know
somebody that's keeping you up
like your nails um
whatever you need you know your clothes
as long as you're elevating i guess it's
a good idea but if
you know i wouldn't give any advice
because this is this
i don't know you know um
i wouldn't do it you wouldn't do it
it's a dangerous life hey you've had
you've had things happen to you yeah
like what
um
i haven't had i've watched some of your
stories and i have not had
what the girls out here have had done to
them uh just horrible stories yeah
so i even contemplated this question and
thought about it i was gonna answer to
you
and
the main i think thing is
abandonment
completely like abandonment like that's
trauma
and that affects you on how you
move with everybody else in your life
um i've been flipped
in memphis when i didn't know what i was
doing you know um which is two people
come in the room
and i thought that
one was gonna go in the bathroom and
wait his turn and when one started the
one from the bathroom came out and you
don't have control after that they're
doing what they're going to do and
um
i mean i haven't been kidnapped i
haven't
and i better knock on someone but do you
carry a gun or knife or masonry
i have mace but you know like
i don't know where you're going to put
mace on the body when you walk in like
this and you might have left something
you know you have a purse or something
no i literally just go in with my phone
and condoms
to condoms
um
i just feel like by the time you are
able to try to defend yourself it's too
late like you're already in
whatever you're about to be in
do you ever have moments where you think
about what you're doing when you're
walking into a stranger's
motel room with your phone and two
condoms that like man what how did i get
into this
not at that point at that point i want
to get it in and get it gone you already
hit for real it's like the high like i
want to get my drug which is the money
and then i want to get gone and then
it's literally like you're in a whole
different you're not even who you are
right like when people are like uh you
know who
asked me a question or which girl do you
want to respond you weren't heather or
you weren't
lillian
yeah
the lillian is the name you go by when
you're working
and today you're working where what city
um i work all over
and i'm not working like anywhere right
now
um i work a full-time job right now oh
you do yeah
i
have been working but
there's too much going on out there
right now
um
and i'm not trying to
go to jail
um
i want to
and i'm going to start
investing in other things
like i want to do real estate and i want
to finish my degree in school
so
i want you know
and this is something that you that
people should be thinking while they're
in it
what you want to do with it
and if it's not being accomplished then
you're not
you're not doing it for the right
reasons anymore maybe you're not if
you're not saving money which it sounds
like
most of the time you weren't
it becomes and that is a tricky question
because
everybody asks us well
what have you saved you don't have
anything saved
tell me a girl in the industry that
hands her money over that
has anything to say
we don't we're not what how you know how
do we save
yeah because we're handing it over
and when it doesn't go right
then we have nothing
so we start all over again that's why
i'm saying like the abandonment is a
trauma
knowing that you did all this
you laid down
literally you went into those situations
that's why i i don't know i wouldn't
i wouldn't advise this life yeah do you
think it takes a woman who's
broken somehow emotionally
to do this kind of work i do
i do because it's a
i think you know how to respond better
when you're emotionally in fact that
you know how to
deal with other people that are messed
up and you know how to deal with hurt
better you know you know how to deal
with abandonment better because you're
ready for the next situation woman who's
loved by your family and
wasn't abused
especially sexually probably would
draw a line about what what she's going
to allow herself to get into right
a lot of these women just end up well
how did you even let
so many of these girls are 13 years old
and they're with pimps and like how does
that happen
it happens because they
were molested when they were eight yeah
or they weren't you know they had no
good role models right their mom and dad
didn't weren't even dad was in prison
mom was on drugs there was no example of
a loving relationship
in that girl's life
so she doesn't even know what that looks
like
and this seems like oh it's enticing
it's glamorous it's
fast money
becomes attractive to a lot of young
girls that it has to end one day
i'm sorry it has to end one day
this is a
young person's game
you get aged out yeah
and fast like especially if you're with
somebody who's feeding you drugs
and i'm just i'm so thankful that
that wasn't me
do you have any regrets in your life
i really don't i think that if you live
with regrets and
i don't know how you live
there's like a burden a negative burden
that
regrets um
yeah mistakes are great learning
opportunities
it's never a
it's never a loss it's always a lesson
what you say is the most important thing
you've learned in your life
most important lesson
okay
lesson
um
you can't trust anybody but that's not
like a positive thing you know you just
have to be positive
sometimes the things you learn are
negative
trust mainly
if you want something then you have to
do it yourself
like literally you have to
just put in the footwork
you have to believe in yourself
you know like i said you can't trust
what anybody else is going to tell you
everybody's looking for something out
for you
it doesn't matter who you are you don't
have to be
a lady of the night
everybody
people don't talk to people
it's not something that
shines right when they
hear your name or see who you are
do you feel like love is
somewhat transactual it's a
the attractiveness of a woman is being
traded for the
financial support of a man
or is there true love where it's like
none of those are really a fact are
these
with the world the way it is right now i
don't know um
it's like i think there's seasons
i think people are good for one another
maybe there's true love maybe like
people
sometimes are beneficial to that one
time in their life and they can stick
with each other and love each other for
50 years that's like way back when but
people get tired and don't work together
and
there's too much stuff on the side that
especially with social media that
is taunting
and
tempting yeah
looks better or can do whatever this one
can't
and that's where we come in at
you know if the if the wives the girls
or
maybe we're doing what they started
doing or but we need them to not be
doing
you know
so it's kind of catch 22 but
i just
you got to believe in polygamy you got
to be able to share
and even if i i didn't start off that
way you know
but i had to get it together
i had to start believing that
because that's what it was going to be
and then your feelings
you have to desensitize you don't feel
but
you know
you don't feel
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story
i wish you the best of luck with
whatever you do from here thank you
thank you very much
you